[Musica]
si no
o meglio la lunga urbana della discarica
ribelle registrano emozioni esplorano
mondi inesplorati e imprevedibili
confronti registrano lo stato di guerra
tra umani e il loro mondo
il collasso delle risorse la crescita
senza fine l'inquinamento la scatenante
rivoluzione tecnico indispensabile
dipendenza dal mondo naturale
l'insaziabile acuti
cercano connessioni con individui umani
interscambi di energia esplorazione
della forma luce silenziosa veggenza il
suono della pioggia hanno appena
iniziato il viaggio di ritorno
un viaggio verso l'energia scrive
francesca lampredi il culmine del
viaggio si raggiunge entrando a contatto
con i mutanti un esercito trionfale dire
sito dart accoglie il visitatore
implorandolo di riconnettersi col mondo
interessanti suggestioni possono
collegare l'installazione all'affresco
di palazzo abatellis di palermo
nell'opera quattrocentesca la morte a
cavallo conduce i suoi fedeli
ranieri ha una purificazione sulla terra
uccidendo soggetti di qualsiasi
estrazione sociale ed età in uno
splendido giardino l'istallazione di
lacquaniti non porta una marval macraba
fine ma alla sua antitesi una completa
rinascita spirituale un nuovo inizio per
l'umanità la vicinanza con l'affresco di
park di palermo e data sia dalla
presenza del condottiero a cavallo che
conduce il suo esercito che dalla
capacità dell'installazione di
stravolgere un vasto pubblico di
qualsiasi età sensibilità ed estrazione
sociale
i mutanti sono elementi autonomi forme
vive ognuno dotato di una propria
personalità composti da materia vibrante
creati tramite l'assemblaggio di oggetti
comuni o materiali industriali e si
riconciliano passato e presente
sono forme bizzarre ironiche ma anche
tragiche guerrieri dell'esistenza figli
dell'industrializzazione si proiettano
nel three adesso per condurci verso una
vera e propria rivoluzione spirituale
come radio captano le emozioni del
visitatore tra cui le più ancestrali
come la paura del mondo
il dolore la tristezza e le inca la nano
nella convivenza nell'accettazione verso
la luce scrive paolo campiglio
sono affascinato da te garba revolution
e da questi personaggi che sono antichi
e moderni
allo stesso tempo sono parte di noi nel
senso che hanno la nostra storia i
nostri oggetti che rifiutiamo e che non
vediamo e che ritornano ci sommergono
sono parte della nostra storia del
presente ma al tempo stesso ricordano il
barocco hanno dentro la storia dell'arte
c'è picasso
c'è tutto il mondo diciamo del passato
anche del novecento che ci sembrava
dimenticato che invece si presenta con
una forza veramente magica scrive
tommaso montanari e poi una vera
rivelazione dentro un capannone sfilano
in silenzio cento figura umanoide un
esercito di mutanti costruiti
d'immondizia e guidati da un cavaliere
solenne inquietante una schiera
imprevedibilmente bella che ricorda
quella delle armate medievali del mood
del museo stibbert di firenze
se solo si potesse hybrid arla con la
fauna intergalattica del bar di guerre
stellari
tutto ebbe inizio a tatò mia a cavallo
di due secoli
a tommy e la raccaforte laboratorio post
industriale dell'artista vive con moglie
e figlia una notte invernale una forza
misteriosa lo chiama si sveglia e senza
alcun indugio inizia il viaggio verso le
sponde del fiume la luna piena il freddo
pungente li rincorrono
tra la montagna di rifiuti salgono fino
in cima e qui tutti i rottami si muovono
l'artista trova delle bacchette della
batteria e istintivamente si improvvisa
maestro dello scarto dirigendo
un'orchestra che lo segue la montagna
incantata della morte si dirige verso
transit il carrozzone del minuto che li
porterà a destinazione aneddoto del
baratto posizionare un barattolo nel
tennessee era rotondo sopra una collina
ciò fece sì che la boscaglia incolta
circondasse la collina la boscaglia si
sollevo fino adesso e lazy distribuì
intorno non più incolta il barattolo e
rotondo sulla terra è alto di una certa
portata aerea ottenne il dominio di
tutto il barattolo era grigio e spoglio
non sapeva di uccello di cespuglio come
del resto niente nel tennessee
questa poesia è stata scritta da wallace
stevens nel 1919 scrive ancora tomaso
montanari sulla repubblica se non
tornerete bambini non entrerete nel
paradiso cioè nel giardino di dio e
questa frase del vangelo di matteo a
martellare la fantasia camminando in uno
stato di grazia nel viaggio di ritorno
che uno spettacolare parco di sculture
contemporanea nel sud della toscana
il ritorno annunciato dal titolo infatti
è un ritornello con l'unione infantile
con la natura e con l'umanità e il
giardino è capace di infondere una
serenità da oasi appunto paradisiaca
tutto comincia nel domino in due quando
rodolfo lacquaniti di architetto nato in
calabria è laureata sia a firenze dove
si manteneva facendo il modello per le
sfilate di pitti lascia la città con la
moglie letizia e la figlia di due anni e
margherita per ristrutturare un casale
nella maremma di castiglion della
pescaia qui guardando alla tradizione
tosco romana che porta dal 5 trincee sco
parco dei mostri di bomarzo al giardino
dei tarocchi di niki de saint phalle a
capalbio lacquaniti dg di far nascere un
giardino di statue ma non lo fa
acquistando i materiali nobili della
tradizione italiana mandando in cerchio
degli scarti industriali raccogliendo i
rifiuti che ingombrano l'organo il
nostro paesaggio dalle lamiere alle
bottiglie di vetro dai vestiti ai tubi
futuribili piovuti dai caccia militari
che decollano dalla base vicina di
grosseto seguendo le regole terapia
architettura e dunque disposti secondi
punti cardinali in comunione con luce
con i venti i rifiuti si sono
trasformati in grande e piccole
installazioni la monumentale balena che
incanta i bambini e che promette di
restituirci migliori come giorno
pinocchio al mare della vita
la sfera luminosa alta otto metri i cui
vetri di fonderia si illuminano
magicamente al tramonto
l'arca dei migranti che fa capire che
questo paradiso non è una fuga dalla
realtà ma un luogo dove attingere la
forza per cambiare il mondo
tuttavia quando lacquaniti parla delle
sue opere non parla mai di rifiuti ma di
scarti e guarda materiali con lo sguardo
amoroso di
il racconto un trovatello di chi ha
saputo scoprire regener negli occhi di
un incompreso e lo stesso linguaggio di
colui che potrebbe essere il più
appassionato visitatore del giardino
papà francesco che ha fatto della
riflessione sugli scarti e sugli
scartati dalla società interno della sua
predicazione per realizzare il suo
giardino lacquaniti ha lasciato firenze
che ormai la capitale mondiale di
un'arte ridotta al lusso un'arte in
vendita che celebra l'onnipotenza del
mercato e il culto del denaro
remotissima da tutto questa è la frase
che vergogna d'ischia marmo tu hai un
dono di dio
addirittura e non venderti perché è ora
il papa che scrive il ruolo dell'artista
e contrastare la cultura dello scarto e
denunciare alla sporcizia frughino più
brutta
il dio denaro conoscere in tanti di
giardino del viaggio di ritorno
significa comprendere tutto questo
perché esiste un altra arte un'arte che
serve a tornare
a tornare umano qualunque produzione
creativa nasce da una base misteriosa
ispirazione ecco e prende forma
attraverso la meditazione di un'allergia
di traduzione e comunicazione
un artista nel momento dell'atto
creativo dovrebbe aprirsi alle forze
dell'assoluto come dice ring alla lata
energia creare dalla possibilità dalla
possibilità di bypassare lio il film
quotidiano concentrato su di noi si
ferma e attraverso i tagli si accede
all'oltre connettendoci con il tutto le
tecnologie ci fanno viaggiare dentro
piazze virtuali ci aiutano nelle
comunicazioni nelle medicine in tanti
altri campi
nello stesso tempo sono fonte di non
presenza esistono dentro di noi
connessione attraverso le quali si può
viaggiare oltre la luce come dice borghi
la mente potrebbe avere una struttura
simile a quella dell'universo è in atto
una grande rivoluzione e i giovani
dovranno gestirla
si passerà dalla terza età delle energie
fosse di alla quarta delle rinnovabili
col tempo le generazioni future dovranno
fare un salto straordinario per arrivare
alla quinta era quella che finalmente
vedrà la fine di ogni conflitto sul
pianeta terra e regnare alla pace e la
felicità l'amore sono allora gli alieni
si avvicenderanno a noi terrestri
scrive il poeta kunming l'amore è un
luogo e in questo luogo d amore si
muovono con luminosità e pace tutti i
luoghi
il sì è un mondo e in questo mondo di si
vivono sagacemente rannicchiati tutti i
mondi quando saremo pronti a tutto
questi sì allora saremmo veramente
liberi
scrive david foster wallace in questa è
l'acqua ci sono due giovani pesci che
nuotano uno vicino all'altro e incontro
non pesce più anziano che nuotando in
direzione opposta fa allora un cenno di
saluto e poi dice buongiorno ragazzi
come l'acqua
i due giovani pesci mi continuano a
notare per un po e poi uno dei due
guarda l'altro e gli chiede ma cosa
diavolo el acqua ma cosa diavolo e la
bellezza ci domandiamo possiamo dire che
un'opera si appella anche se il
materiale con cui viene prodotta
inquinante l'artista è consapevole di
far parte di una catena che contribuisce
alla distruzione della bellezza cioè del
nostro paese pianeta nel 2018 e nate
alla biennale dello scarto una biennale
pirata che vuole provocare e nello
stesso tempo per far riflettere su
alcuni temi contemporanei e una biennale
itinerante
che avvalendosi delle ultime tele
tecnologie teletrasporta le opere vuole
essere anche un atto di denuncia con
un'arte che spreca inquina abbiamo
realizzato balene ars che anci di
mutanti e tante altre opere che prendono
vita iniziano un viaggio interattivo
realizzato col contributo dello studio
web di firenze di diego capani spaziando
tra oceani città piazze luoghi naturali
continenti remoti esplorando l'utopia
perché l'arte deve essere un vero e
proprio corpo circuito la biennale di
venezia è partita proprio da venezia la
biennale dello scarpe ed è scandita
dalla danza delle balene finisco con
questa scrittura che leggo davanti
all'arca nel parco
del viaggio di ritorno si chiama questo
noi questo non è destinata a vagare non
si sa se mai riuscirà a toccare terra
come nella raffigurazione del nel defoe
di bosch il vascello naviga senza meta
porta con sé pare galleggianti muri che
dividono nord e sud ricchi e poveri chi
perseguita chi soffre porta chi ha le
chiavi del progresso e dell'informazione
e chi è condannata a vivere
nell'ignoranza nel buio porta lo sguardo
del angius novus di polk di paul click e
benjamin descrive come una creatura
sventurata trascinata dalla patente
dalla tempesta del progresso con lo
sguardo fisso all indietro su un cumulo
di macerie alte fino al cielo
porta le lamiere delle baracca di le
favelas oppure quelle del cairo porta
diseredati vittime di guerra profughi
privati della loro libertà sfruttati
tenuti ai margini della società porta
intarsio sorridente il leopardo
dell'amur il sociale del reggente porta
mammiferi uccelli insetti rettili tutti
quelli che sono a rischio di estinzione
porta con sé la giungla pluviale che
lentamente scompare ogni mese un milione
di ettari porta i ghiacciai della
groenlandia che si stanno sciogliendo a
un ritmo vertiginoso porta al cemento
chi avanza ovunque soltanto 250 ettari
al giorno solo in europa porta
continenti di plastica abbassati
ma porta anche con sé ali tremanti di
adolescenti liberi di vagare di agire
alla ricerca di prospettive originali
scoperte eccitanti di territori
inesplorati porta l'animale da cui
proveniamo
il ventre dove la nascita avuto luogo al
riparo di tutto porta la felicità
interiore l'energia creativa porta la
bellezza che ci circonda l'azzurro del
cielo
l'armonia della natura la leggerezza dei
bambini delle donne degli uomini di
questo meraviglioso pianeta portale arci
l'architettura tutte le civiltà che ci
hanno preceduto e che vanno
salvaguardate perché noi siamo loro
portale fogli brillanti di ulivo lo
spazio sacro che abita in tutti gli
esseri viventi dell'universo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
o
[Musica]